-You know, I texted you pretty
much after every episode.
"Last Man"
was such a fantastic show.
Congratulations.
-Thank you very much.
-Five years?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Aww, thanks.
-I know you didn't,
as you wrote --
I thought it had
a wonderful ending.
I know you did not fully know
that that would be your last
season as you wrote it.
So then did you have ideas
for other things
that you did not get
a chance to do?
-We knew very fully
how we would handle
the cliffhanger version
leading off into a fifth season,
but we weren't sure how we would
do the final ending of the show.
There were a couple things
along the way,
a couple ideas along the way
of how to ultimately end it.
One of them was this idea
of talking --
of the very final segment
of the show
would be me in the offices
at Fox
pitching them the show.
And then them asking,
"Okay, okay,
so we understand all that,
but what is this show about?"
And then it would just be me
sitting there
for like three minutes
and then then just going,
"I don't know."
[ Laughter ]
And then it would end.
And then there was one other,
very weird ending that I wrote.
I have it right here.
-Oh, you have it?
-Yeah, I have it right here.
So it would start on a cat
with its eyes closed.
-Uh-huh.
-And then you would hear
my voice coming in saying,
"Pebbles? Pebbles.
Pebbles."
Then the cats eyes open
and you would see Tandy
standing over the cat
and I would say,
"What's up with you?
You have a little cat dream?"
And then there's no response.
And I'd say, "Do you want to
tell me about it?"
And then Carol, Kristen Schaal's
character, Carol comes in
and says "Tandy,
That's so silly.
We all know cats can't talk...
unless they have their
vocalization collars on."
So we put a collar on the cat.
[ Laughter ]
Slide it around the cat and then
the cat starts talking.
And the cat says,
"I had the craziest dream.
You both were in it.
Tandy, you were an idiot."
And then it goes on to be
this "Wizard of Oz"-type ending
where every character
from the show comes in.
-The whole show
was the cat's dream?
-Yeah, it was the cat's dream.
-Oh, my God.
-People were not crazy about it.
-They were not crazy about it?
-They were not crazy about it.
And I don't know, maybe Fox
caught wind of this
and, like, canceled the show.
They're like, "We're out.
We're fully out."
[ Laughter ]